Замість маршруток і метро кияни Лія і Філіп пересуваються містом
на легкому персональному транспорті. Хлопець майже рік користується електросамокатом
і їздить переважно в центрі столиці.
Я не очікував, що настільки це буде швидко, настільки це буде комфортно
навіть у порівнянні з велосипедом.
У дівчини вже третє за три роки моноколесо
і щоденний маршрут з лівого на правий берег Дніпра.
Це насамперед задоволення! Не складно ні для ніг, ні для тіла.
Обоє молодих людей підхопили тренд мікромобільності, який стрімко набирає обертів
не тільки в Києві, а й в інших українських містах-мільйонниках.
У столиці на вулиці щоденно виїздить понад 1000 самокатів
від п'яти різних сервісів прокату. Скільки киян користуються власними
електроскутерами, наразі ще ніхто не порахував. У цей потік також вливаються
велосипедисти та "моноколісники". Лише офіційна спільнота останніх
нараховує понад 800 людей. Такий бум мікромобільності викрив чимало проблем
в інфраструктурі міст і законодавстві про правила дорожнього руху.
Знімальна група DW супроводжує Лію та Філіпа на звичних для них маршрутах,
аби показати, як вони пересуваються легким персональним транспортом
і чи дійсно з ним можна забути про громадський.
Філіп за майже рік користування електросамокатом проїхав на ньому
близько 1200 кілометрів. Цієї дистанції вистачило, аби виробити
для себе основні правила виживання на дорозі.
У прокладанні руху з точки А в точку Б я звертаю увагу на комфорт і безпеку.
Я надаю перевагу проїжджій частині, там швидше і комфортніше, менше ям,
ніж на тротуарах, рідше треба спішуватися. Є такі вулиці, на яких дорогою їздити
надто небезпечно по моїм особистим відчуттям.
Лія починала з легкого моноколеса і сприймала катання на ньому радше як розвагу.
Переглянути погляди змусила пандемія. Тоді ж дівчина купила потужнішу модель,
тюнінгувала її і почала використовувати як основний вид транспорту.
Їздила на моноколесі навіть взимку. На відміну від Філіпа смуг для автівок дівчина уникає.
У мене немає прав, тому я по дорогах не їжджу, оскільки там зустрічаються у крайній правій смузі
відкриті люки, каміння, припарковані автівки.
Якщо автівки починають притискати, таке буває справді. Вони притискають моноколісника
до бордюра, не розуміючи того, як управляти колесом. А у нас якщо зачепитися педаллю,
це означає падіння. І оскільки у крайній смузі швидкість на дорозі розвивається
доволі велика, це може взагалі привести до летальних наслідків.
З досвіду Лії така небезпека часто чатує на водіїв моноколіс на мостах через Дніпро.
Автомобільний трафік на них інтенсивний, а от інфраструктура
для альтернативного транспорту не передбачена. Дівчині пощастило,
що найближчий для неї шляхопровід - виняток і на ньому є відділений під електротранспорт
і велосипеди простір.
Тут виділили окрему смугу. Ймовірно, щоб розвантажити міст Патона,  бо він у аварійному стані.
У цих відбійниках має бути вода, щоб у випадку зіткнення авто не могло вилетіти на райдера.
Тому я завжди, коли їду, дивлюся у дзеркало заднього виду, контролюю ситуацію.
Де і як мають пересуватися водії електротранспорту, українське законодавство не визначає.
Для нього електросамокатів і моноколіс де-юре не існує взагалі.
У Верховній Раді ще з осені лежить проголосований у першому читанні законопроєкт.
Він попередньо передбачає право їздити альтернативному транспорту велодоріжками
чи крайньою смугою доріг.
Урбаніст і радник заступника КМДА Віталій Селик каже, що через дискусії довкола документа,
його можуть проголосувати не раніше осені. А потреба навести лад у цій сфері вже вкрай актуальна.
У цьому році спостерігається величезний бум. В Києві очікується до 8 тисяч самокатів.
Зараз це близько тисячі. Ще не так страшно, але вже дуже помітно.
Одне з конфліктних питань, чи випускати самокати на тротуари чи ні.
А якщо заборонити їм рухатися по тротуарам, то хто буде за ними бігати.
В законі варто було б розділити, що тротуар залишається для пішоходів,
дорога для автомобіля, а велодоріжки, власне, для велосипедів і цих засобів мікромобільності.
Для Лії і Філіпа велодоріжки - ідеальний простір для руху. Але сьогодні їх в Києві всього 120 кілометрів
із більше, ніж 1000 потрібних. До того ж у центрі містах на них ще й часто паркуються машини,
а в зелених зонах ходять пішоходи.
Велодоріжки є, але вони починаються і закінчуються невідомо де.
До прикладу, ця велодоріжка погана тим, що вона дуже вузька.
Дуже складно розминутися двом власникам легкого персонального транспорту.
І ще як бачите, є яма.
Погане дорожнє покриття регулярно трапляється на маршрутах у обох водіїв електротранспорту,
як у самісінькому центрі столиці, так і на околиці. Однак долають ці перешкоди
моноколесо і електросамокат по-різному.
Моноколесо проїздить багато де, нам не страшні бордюри, лежачі поліцейські.
Ми їх успішно долаємо, єдине просто потрібно завжди бути на сторожі,
як і власне, на будь-якому транспорті.
Часто бувають такі ситуації, коли і дорога, і тротуар - вони всі в ямах і це звісно найгірша історія,
яка може бути, бо тоді ти стаєш тим, хто возить самокат, а не навпаки.
Возити і носити на собі 17 кілограмовий самокат Філіпові доводиться мало не щодня
ще й через відсутність безбар’єрного середовища у столиці.
Це ще один приклад мобільності в Києві, особливо інклюзивності.
Він 17 кілограмів важить, я його можу підняти. Але це ж не тільки про легкий персональний транспорт.
А про всі маломобільні групи населення деякі самокати по 30 кг важать
і без якихось адекватних умов, і постійних сходинок це теж некомфортно, і це теж те,
що відбиває бажання або може відбити бажання у багатьох людей пересідати на такий
хороший екологічний вид транспорту.
Серед недоліків користування електросамокатом Філіп називає ще й погоду.
Взимку і восени хлопцю довелося повернутися до піших прогулянок і громадського транспорту.
Їздити на скутері було небезпечно та некомфортно. Однак попри це та нерозвинену інфраструктуру Києва
Філіп за рік користування власним самокатом вбачає у ньому більше переваг, ніж труднощів.
З самокатом простіше комбінувати шлях з громадським транспортом.
Так само в будь-який момент треба зайти в магазин, береш самокат,
навіть складати в принципі не треба. На роботу коли я їду, я доїжджаю швидше,
я доїжджаю чистим , мені не треба йти в душ, ще одна перевага над велосипедом,
тобто я не пітнію і зі мною все ок, відповідно ще економиться час.
Лія ж завдяки моноколесу знайшла ще й нових друзів.
Власники цього електротранспорту згуртувалися у потужну спільноту,
яка регулярно проводить спільні катання, відстоює свої права і навіть в очікуванні законодавчих змін
вводить внутрішні правила для користувачів, як от їздити тротуарами не швидше 10 км/год,
не наближатися впритул до пішоходів, носити захисні і світловідбиваючі елементи одягу,
а ще бути передбачуваними для водіїв. Водночас сподіваються, що при укладанні
законопроєкту інтереси спільноти теж врахують.
Важливо, щоб ті, хто ухвалюватимуть рішення і вводять правила
по легкому персональному транспорту, були власниками такого транспорту.
Тим часом з суто столичної забави за менш як рік сервіс електросамокатів
став дійсно популярним і безпечним альтернативним транспортом.
Тепер скутери доступні для оренди також у Львові, Харкові, Одесі, Дніпрі.
За спостереженнями співвласника магазин  у вело- й електротранспорту
та одного із сервісів прокату Олексія Кушки, ця тенденція й надалі зростатиме.
Хоча бізнес і має свої особливості, як-от велику конкуренцію
і зношуваність електроскутерів.
Попит на продажі таких девайсів зріс в майже 2-2,5 рази. Ті, хто використовував прокатні сервіси,
це приблизно в 4 рази підвищився попит на самокати. В принципі він вже є альтернативою.
А якщо будуть відповідні закони, що обмежать в’їзд в центральну частину міста
автівкам, то звичайно, це буде ще більший бум.
У КМДА вирішили не чекати ухвалення закону, який би врегулював користування електротранспортом,
і вже готують меморандум про співпрацю з власниками прокатних компаній,
де пропишуть базові правила їх використання у місті.
Можливо, варто було б технічно зменшити швидкість самокатів для того,
щоб при ймовірному зіткненні з пішоходами, травмування було менш помітним, чи, можливо,
треба було б збирати податки з цих же самокатників для того, щоб за ці податки
можна було розвивати велоінфраструктури в місті так само, як це відбувається з автомобілістами,
і ці гроші потім йдуть на розбудову доріг.
У КМДА обіцяють невдовзі полегшити життя власникам легкого персонального транспорту
ще й виділенням так званих антиковідних велодоріжок.
Це коли під велосипеди, моноколеса і скутери просто віддають одну з автомобільних смуг дороги.
Таке вже активно практикують у Європі, зокрема в Німеччині,
аби заохотити людей до мікромобільності в часи пандемії.